all right 100 yes sir 100 uh where are
you from originally where do you grow up
uh i mean tell the two cities i'm
originally from milwaukee you know
raised in kansas city you know
meal made kansas city race
milwaukee wisconsin
and tell her what your family
my family who you want to hear about
first
i got a big family man
your mom and dad yeah mom
yeah mom you know hard worker you know
nine or fives like my whole life
everything like that
you know did the best she could you know
what i'm saying like we never it's not
one of those stories you know i'm saying
words like you know we had to struggle
to survive you know we we didn't really
have much but we we had enough to make
it to the next season for sure you know
i just always been a man of abundance
you know i'm saying so
but nonetheless like she put clothes on
my back she put food in my mouth and i
had a roof over my head for sure
where was that
uh you know he he was
in out in and out of the penitentiary
and things like that you know he did the
best he could as well you know they had
me at a young age 17 and 18.
so you know he was just trying you know
me per se i'm 25 and i don't feel like
i'm um
as ready for kids you know as i would
have been at 17 or 18. so you know he
was in and out of jail and um just doing
the best he could you know he made
things happen from the inside as well so
how would you describe your childhood in
general
uh how i would describe it in general i
would describe it as a
it depends you know because it
in in each moment you know like
sometimes tom have to pass for you to
really appreciate
what was going on right then and there
you know it might not look like it in
real time but i moved around a lot so
within that i'm originally from
milwaukee and when i moved to kansas
city that was kind of like traumatic for
me you know because i wasn't around to
like a lot of family and friends you
know
but um
it it forced me to grow it forced me to
be like who i am today you know i'm
saying like just adapting you know
picking up different picking up
different cultures you know i'm saying
coexisting with different kind of people
i don't think i would be as articulate i
don't think i would be as comfortable
as i would had i just been you know
strict and uh stuck in milwaukee like
just born and raised
for sure it'd be returned you returned
to milwaukee
say it again you're in milwaukee now
um back and forth yeah for sure yeah
back and forth between
yeah milwaukee kansas city milwaukee
kansas city yeah and you finished high
school yeah i finished high school
graduated you got introduced to the game
at what age
um
i moved to vegas around 18 years old
straight out of high school i moved on
my mom's house and everything like that
i went back to milwaukee for probably
about three months and just realized
it's not where i wanted to be so
long story short i ended up in vegas
and um
it's it's some inspiration out there for
sure you know it's some inspiration it's
a it's a lot of you know pretty you know
saying women it's a lot of fly gentlemen
and everything like that but honestly
like when it comes to the game i feel
like everything
is just like everything i am is always
what i've been you know like from like
yay high you know like they say like
people have like love languages and
everything you know i feel like my
introduction wasn't my introduction to
the game it was just
it wasn't it wasn't
it wasn't an introduction to the game
you know i'm saying it was just me
exercising elements of my character that
was already there you know what i'm
saying like i've always been a ladies
kind of person you know i've always
liked gifts and affirmations and things
of that nature you know so
my introduction to the game you know it
it was
it was inspirations from a lot of places
i went you know to get the game is heavy
in milwaukee the game is you know what
i'm saying it's not as heavy but certain
elements is even you know displayed in
kansas city but
when i moved to vegas at 18 it was just
in full throttle you know right before
my eyes it sounds like your personality
is also it lends itself to
yeah for sure to do what you're doing
too for sure
did you have anyone teach you or show
you the ropes
yeah i can't say you know per se i
really had anybody you know take me
under their wings and teach me how to
fly this is you know trial and error you
know i bumped my head a couple of times
you know probably got a lot of mistakes
to make even you know so it's not it's
not you know like self-made self-paced
self-taught and i definitely you know
i'm a listener so i definitely be
amongst men and i be amongst individuals
and and i take what i can and you know i
i soak up i soak up information and if i
can apply it to my life then i will you
know i'm saying but i believe in just
being different and like blazing your
own trail you know to a certain extent
so within that i don't do i don't really
do anything
like they say you can ask you know
uh 10 men the same question and get 10
different answers you know what i'm
saying so it's like i have answers to my
own questions sometimes but if i don't
know i don't i don't mind you know
calling a friend or play a partner or
whatever the case may be like i don't
you know i don't mind asking for help
but for the most part i
yeah what's more important to you a lot
of money what's more important
love or money i mean love love make the
world go around you know what i'm saying
like money is going to come and go you
know what i'm saying but it's like when
you love what you do you look in the
mirror you love who you are you know
what i'm saying it's like
you know you you get like-minded
individuals around you you know i'm
saying this like i can't really have you
around me
if i don't have some type of love for
you because i love me you know what i'm
saying that mean i love my energy i love
my space you know what i'm saying i love
my peace of mind so to a certain extent
you know like i love everything i am and
i love everything around me you know
what i'm saying like i'm a pisces you
know i'm a worldly kind of person you
know what i'm saying so it's all i love
with me now the money is going to come
it always came you know
you're you're
you're part of a
a small
community that's one of the most hated
right for sure in in society
you know pimps are just hated across the
board without any kind of consideration
of
what role they play in these women's
lives right
how do you
defend your position as a as a p i mean
it's not it's not a matter of you know
like
me defending anything it's a matter of
just being just being an example you
know what i'm saying like it's easy to
hate something you know nothing about
you know what i'm saying like i don't
know anything about the war but if you
tell me it's a war going on you know i'm
saying like by default i'm probably
going to hate the other side you know
what i'm saying so and it's like i'm not
into politics i don't know the war you
feel me i've never met any of the
sergeants anybody out there you know but
it's like once
like we all humans at the end of the day
you know i'm saying i'm man she's woman
you know i'm saying so within that if
it's something about me that you could
take a liking to then take a liking to
it if it's not if it's something about
me that you hate
that you genuinely hate because you know
you've been around me and you observed
me and you've seen these attributes then
hate me you know what i'm saying who am
i to tell you how to feel about me i can
only know how i feel about me and how i
feel about you i don't hate anybody you
know it's all love with me yeah you know
tell me tell me exactly how a girl
goes from
first off how do you find a girl
well
he finds you
yeah i just you know i just look around
and you know she's looking at me and you
know we make eye contact you know i you
know may approach her she may approach
me and we just see if there's
compatibility there that's all i guess
where i'm leading with this is
in defense of pimps right
very often these girls are
they come from broken homes right
they're in the streets
they're just trying to survive right
they're very very bad with money
incredibly bad with money right right
but they they have the ability to make
money for sure and they get nowhere
and that's where you come into the
picture
right i'm putting words in your mouth
but tell me how far off face i am i mean
you you summed it up pretty good but you
know me per se i like to think uh it
takes one to know one you know what i'm
saying so if you coming from a broken
place you know i'm saying like i have to
be relatable to that broken place to a
certain extent you know i'm saying it's
just
some people haven't took out the time to
really dedicate themselves and and heal
those broken places in those broken
wombs and everything so it's like if a
woman come into my life and i can help
her with that because i've been through
that you know i'm saying then i'm at an
advantage you know what i'm saying and
it's not me taking advantage it's just
me being relatable i understand what
you're going through you know what i'm
saying you got to go through it to get
to it let's go through it and get to it
together you'll help her manage your
money a little better yeah for sure
absolutely yeah make sure she's
looking good and
looking good feeling good you know it's
like i i i start with the mind you know
what i'm saying like it's just
confidence you know i'm saying you
looking in the mirror you know saying
you you have you have to you have to
tell yourself certain things you know
what i'm saying even if she never felt
like she was beautiful you know i'm
saying i like her to reiterate that
she's beautiful you know what i'm saying
i like her to reiterate that she's
abundant you know i'm saying the world
is hers for the taking you know i like
her to reiterate you know i'm saying
that you know it's nothing you know her
her possibilities are endless you know
what i'm saying so i think it's some
it's training you know i'm saying just a
matter of what you tell yourself on a
day-to-day basis for sure you describe
your role in her life i mean
there's so many things you could
describe it as like a life coach
yeah a life a life coach a mentor you
know what i'm saying nonetheless yeah
you know what i'm saying a mentor a life
coach you know i'm saying a financial
advisor
you know
i'm five five i'm not much security you
know what i'm saying like i can't lie to
you but i can't tell you know how to
conduct yourself though you know i'm
saying sometimes sometimes things may
transpire and everything like that where
you have to defend yourself you know i'm
saying but first and foremost it's a
matter of not panicking and defending
yourself with your mind and analyzing
the situation first and i could train
you how to do that for sure i could
train you how to do that you know what
i'm saying but i don't know karate you
know what i'm saying no taekwondo or
anything like that but for the most part
i feel like you know situations get out
of hand because people react in a
negative kind of fashion you know i'm
saying but i don't feel like there's any
situation you probably can't talk to
talk through or finesse your way through
or you know you know false tears your
way through or anything like that so
it's just a matter of having a game
about yourself you know i'm saying
nonetheless some situations you make it
out of some situations you don't you
know i'm saying but
tell me about the learning process of
you know getting getting
learning the ropes of the game
uh for me or young women for you for you
like what kind of things do you
you must have stories of things you
learned i mean you know i'm i'm still a
student in my game in a game myself you
know i have a long way to go you know
what i'm saying but i i have i have
moments i'm not proud of you i'm saying
i i've experienced things you know i'm
saying like that they were called green
in the game and everything like that and
um early on i think it was just a matter
of
you know like the game has always been
an inspiration to me you know what i'm
saying so like i'm from milwaukee you
know what i'm saying so you got peppa
snookie you got pimping king you know
what i'm saying and i think they just uh
exercised you know the gift of gab and i
took a liking to that you know i'm
saying just being articulate you know
what i'm saying but then you have you
know certain individuals you know i'm
saying who actually have intellectual
properties and you know what i'm saying
it's just a matter of like this
different inspirations but nonetheless i
feel like authenticity is like key i
went through a stage like when i was
younger where it's not that i was going
through an identity crisis but it was
like you would think it's like one way
to do things you know i'm saying but
what works for you may not work for me
and we'll wait what works for me may not
work for you you know i'm saying so you
know i read the books i watched the
videos and everything and whoopty woo
you know and you would think you know
you you hear certain individuals and
it's like you know i'm saying you gotta
smack a [ __ ] it's only right you know
what i'm saying like that's that's
that's the first key you're not doing
anything unless you smack a [ __ ] you
feel me but you you you you find out you
know that's false and everything like
that and and then i'm just like a person
you know i'm a non-violent person you
know what i'm saying so that never
resonated with me you know i'm saying so
it was times like where i had to
question like the game you know what i'm
saying like or certain you feel me like
teaching you i'm saying like that i
found not to be true because just like
you know you and like everybody else you
know i'm saying it's a lot of
misconceptions and it's a lot of you
know people feel like you know it's
monstrous behaviors going on nonetheless
you know there are discipline
disciplinary actions that like take
place in certain households and
everything you know they call them like
gorilla pimps or whatever the case may
be but that's just never been my style
you know what is your style uh i i like
to consider myself you know just the
ultimate gentleman the ultimate
gentleman you know just cut from the old
old school clothes right i mean you
dressed like a 70s 80s now
man i just got this the other day this
is 2022 man
i got you i appreciate you i appreciate
you yeah i've always took a i always
took pride in fashion like for sure you
know i definitely look up to uh some of
the ones that like did it in a
respectable fashion like for sure
for sure yeah because like i'm from
l.a right and they're all they're all
tennis shoe tins yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah everybody can't put that [ __ ] on
man everybody can't put that [ __ ] on you
know you're a product of your
environment you know i i grew up you
know i'm saying around flightness to a
certain extent my dad was a fly guy you
know i'm saying he wasn't no pimping but
he was definitely fly you know suited
and booted and uh you know perm long
hair i grew up wanting a perm and
everything you know he drove a cadillac
and you know what i'm saying it was just
certain elements that resonated with the
game but my dad was not of the game but
nonetheless he definitely uh he had
access to [ __ ] and everything like
that so what what do your parents think
of your lifestyle
um it's it's um
it's pretty much you know like they know
me they know my character you know what
i'm saying like my mother you know i'm
saying she's had you know
she's had the platform to meet women you
know i'm saying it and my mom both you
know what i'm saying is he treating you
right you know what i'm saying like you
know i've had i've had young ladies you
know i'm saying who come into my life
you know with children and everything
you know so it's like
it's it's a matter of handling your
business like as a man you know what i'm
saying i don't i don't hide nothing you
know i'm saying like what you see is
what you get you know what i'm saying so
it's nothing for her to be ashamed of
really you know
so the girls will bring you the money
yeah and in exchange for that you're
kind of
you're really helping them to
improve the quality of their lives yeah
for sure absolutely you know i just make
the money you know make the money make
more money you know find avenues you
know i'm saying put you in the right
places in the right faces and everything
like that and just you know exercise
your feminine energy you know and your
intellectual properties once you get
there you know i'm saying like i'm not
you know me and my women like we read
together you know what i'm saying like
we uh we we you know quality time you
know what i'm saying we we take time to
self-observe you know what i'm saying to
reflect you know what i'm saying it's
all about just being the ultimate person
you know i'm saying being the ultimate
you that you can be you know i'm saying
like i wake up and see how i can be
better than yesterday you know what i'm
saying i want i want women in my life to
wake up and see
how they can be better than yesterday
you know and and it's i'm not i'm not
i'm not perfect i'm not perfect you know
what i'm saying so like within that i'm
constantly growing because i want to be
the ultimate me that i can be you know
i'm saying i want the same for everybody
around me not just the women in my life
i want that for my mom i want that for
my dad i want that for my sister i want
that for my brother so i'm going to give
you that constructive criticism now what
you do with that information once you
get it that's on you you know what i'm
saying but if i see a flaw a character
flaw or i see
a personality trait that can use some
work i'm going to bring that to your
table i'm going to bring that to your
attention and and if you choose and you
want to be better you want to be the
ultimate you either you're going to
address it or you won't address it you
know
and your girls you you and your girls
stay in apartments or house or
motels
uh you know we we've experienced we
we've experienced a couple places you
know i'm saying apartments hotels and
everything you know the living
conditions they they're they're up to
par that's a part for sure and are drugs
a part of your life no absolutely not
you know i might i might have a drink
every now and again but for the most
part you know i got a clean campaign you
know what i'm saying like i want i want
you to be sober i want to be sober and
because clarity is everything you know
the mind is the mind is a beautiful
thing and a terrible thing to waste you
know what i'm saying so we don't need
pollution there you know i'm saying like
i need you to be a shark thinker because
i need to be a shark thinker you know i
need you know we're here to balance each
other out as man and woman you know what
i'm saying sometimes there might be
something that you can't see and i see
and vice versa you know what i'm saying
but you can't do that you know i'm
saying under
under under the influence of anything
really honestly you know what i'm saying
but at the end of the day like these
women like they are grown they make
their own decisions to a certain extent
and everything like that so i'm not
saying you can't go out and have a drink
or whatever the case may be but it's
just a matter of like conducting
yourself like a lady at all times that's
what it's about for me and just to be
clear your girls are not being forced or
manipulated no absolutely not you know
like this on their own yeah you know
like before you know i force anybody to
do anything you know i'm saying like you
can go your separate ways you can have
the money you know what i'm saying like
if you want to be in my life i want you
to be in my life if you qualify to be in
my life if you don't then we can go our
separate ways you know just don't slam
no doors or break no windows on your way
out and everything is cool you know what
i'm saying like i want you to be i want
you to be to me what i am to you you
know what i'm saying like i'm going to
be respectful you know what i'm saying
i'm going to be upfront i'm going to be
honest i'm going to be loyal you know
what i'm saying and these are the and
i'm leading my example so once i show
you these qualities i want the same in
return you know what i'm saying because
if i'm not receiving the same in return
you can keep your money you know what
i'm saying like i don't like i'm okay
i'm i'm well off to a certain extent you
know
are uh are the pimps in milwaukee
similar to the ones in l.a where they're
just
dressing down and uh uh milwaukee always
had
milwaukee always had their own sense of
life style and fashion you know what i'm
saying so it's like sometimes like
dressing down
to you you feel me like
maybe you know
the ultimate putting that [ __ ] on in
milwaukee you know what i'm saying so
it's just a matter of a tale of two
cities two different cultures and
everything like that you know what i'm
saying like like this it's a regular day
in the life for me you know i'm saying i
wouldn't call this dressing up you know
what i'm saying a lot of people they
would call it dressing up though so it's
just a matter of it's just a matter of
your style it's just a matter of you
know what i'm saying and with milwaukee
like we have certain brands and we have
certain stores and everything like that
where you have to go find certain
ingredients you know i'm saying
especially like when you you're you're
you don't have a million dollars in your
pocket and you can't just go to louis
vuitton or versace or whatever the case
may be it's about taking those
ingredients and putting them together in
in a in a in a fashion kind of sense you
know what do you make of uh
the technology that's kind of come into
the game now where a lot of
i mean i don't know using only fans as a
way to make money i mean i don't you
know only fans you know like only fans
is a platform you know what i'm saying
but before only fans you know there were
other platforms you know i'm saying it's
just only fans is just
you know it's just it's just directions
that's all it is you know what i'm
saying it's like hey i'm going to build
this website you upload your pictures
you upload your videos we're going to
pay you with
you with you will i'm not against it but
i'm not for it you know what i'm saying
because at the end of the day that's
something like we can do by ourselves
that's something we can do you know i'm
saying like let's cut out the middle man
let's really get to it you know what i'm
saying but nonetheless you know what i'm
saying it's different strokes for
different folks you know i'm saying if
you have a platform you got a hundred
thousand followers and you can use
only fans to your advantage i'm saying
to
occur some passive income then let's do
it you know let's do it like i don't i
don't feel like it should be obsolete
you know what i'm saying like everything
grows everything evolves you know what
i'm saying and that's what we have to do
as people as well you know what i'm
saying so i think it's just a matter of
adapting i'm not you know what i'm
saying i'm not riot and [ __ ] only fans
or whatever the case may be you know i'm
saying it's a matter of using it to your
advantage if you can if not if you don't
belong in your program you don't see a
way it's beneficial then hey don't use
it you know what i'm saying like that's
that's my personal intake on it but if
you know like i
like
like social media in itself is like a
drug right now you know what i'm saying
like and since it came out it's always
been a drug like [ __ ] i had facebook
since i was like probably nine years old
before that i had a myspace you know i'm
only 25. you know what i'm saying so
regardless it's like attention attention
seeking is like a real thing you know
what i'm saying and believe it or not
some young ladies and even men you know
well
boys or whatever the case may be like
they rather have the likes than the
money you know what i'm saying they
rather have that attention than the
money you know what i'm saying as long
as some people as long as they look good
on instagram they don't give a [ __ ] if
they got to eat noodles they got to
sleep on the floor they got to do this
they got to starve they can't call their
mom because they can't pay their cell
phone bill they giving them likes on
instagram it's all good you know what
i'm saying like me i like my uh
i like my social media platform to to
reflect you know i'm saying what i truly
am because i'm not perfect i still got
some growing to do i still got some
money to obtain you know what i'm saying
but at the end of the day it's like what
you see is what you get you know what
i'm saying in front of the camera and
behind the camera and you know so
only fans i don't have a problem with it
uh problem with it at all
what do you look for in a girl
what do i look for in a girl
are there personality traits or
um what is it
i mean for sure you know like
it's just a matter of us like i need you
to be able to understand me you know
what i'm saying everybody want to be
understood and i'm not obsolete for that
i want you to understand me and then
return understand me and in return i
want to understand you you feel me and
it's a matter of us being compatible you
know i like i like feminine energy you
know i'm saying i like a woman you know
what i'm saying and
whatever you are i want you to be the
ultimate that so you don't have to come
to me perfect because
you know if
if you're not as ladylike as i would
like you to be like i said i'm going to
bring it to your attention you know i'm
saying like hey let's work on this
together you feel me but i want you to
be the ultimate everything you know i'm
saying long as you want to be like i
can't tell you who to be and what to be
i can only see to it that you want to be
the best you that you can be if you're a
mother i want you to be the ultimate
mother you know what i'm saying so i
just look for somebody with drive with
confidence you know what i'm saying
with a willingness to go further and
want to do their best that's all
that's all it's no you know like a lot
of people you know contrary to popular
belief you know people say like you know
you may be looking for a woman that's
like broken or you know i'm saying in
distressed or depressed and everything
and nonetheless those women like do come
along you know i'm saying and if you can
be a helping hand then do so you know
what i'm saying because that is a part
of the game but i'm a builder you know
i'm saying so i don't mind having a
project i don't need you to come to me
perfect you know what i'm saying
i want you to come to me striving to be
perfect though
that's what i like
you know saying like a woman that just
she don't have to know
she just have to want to know
you know she don't have to do she just
have to want to do you know they don't
have to be done already when you come to
me but we have to strive to get it done
is there a romantic component to these
relationships
yeah for sure
for sure you know with you know it's a
matter of you know we're going we're
going to get some money you know what
i'm saying but i feel like you know man
and woman you know i'm saying that
intimacy is like important like for sure
you know i'm saying like you know some
guys don't believe you know what i'm
saying taking [ __ ] to a movie or with
if i want to go to the movie with the
young lady in my life you know i'm
saying we gonna do that you know what
i'm saying what happens when there's
three or four young ladies then we're
all going to the movies you know i'm
saying y'all hold hands and i'ma sit
over here and
we're going to enjoy this movie together
like nonetheless it's like yeah i
believe in quality time you know what
i'm saying i believe in you know i just
don't believe in you know too much of
anything you know what i'm saying like
this game is about in my personal
opinion you know i'm saying like
emotional intelligence you know i'm
saying i don't want you too consumed
with your feelings i'm saying because i
want you to exercise your right to think
i want you to exercise those thoughts i
want you to exercise your right to
really analyze and understand what
you're going through and what you're
going to go through and what you're
doing and what you've done you know what
i'm saying so when people get in their
emotions you feel me like sometimes
things get blurry sometimes things get
you know i'm saying misconstrued you
know what i'm saying because feelings
like it it's it's
they're tied to passion you know what
i'm saying if you're angry you're going
to be angry if you're happy you're going
to be happy you know what i'm saying so
i want your emotions to line up with
logic that's all
you know and i feel like spending too
much time
may distract you from what's important
you know too much affection may distract
you from what's important you know i'm
saying too much you know intimacy may
distract you from what's important you
know
and what would you say is the most
important lesson you learned in your
life
the most important lesson i've learned
in my life why are you dropping these
bombs on me like this you're 25.
yeah the most important lesson
you've learned lately
uh just
just being you just being authentic you
know what i'm saying because it's like
what's for you is going to be for you
what's not is not going to be for you
you know what i'm saying and if you have
to
fake something or someone to obtain
something you're not gonna enjoy it once
you get it because that was never you
and it was never for you you know what
i'm saying that present that gift was
for
who they thought you were you know what
i'm saying so it's just a matter of you
know i'm saying exercise in your
authenticity life for sure and just
being true to who you are you know what
i'm saying because i feel like you know
we all gifted you know what i'm saying
and in order to receive those gifts and
appreciate those gifts you have to
understand
the address that those gifts are on for
sure so just be you it's nice to meet a
young man in the game with principals
for sure who believes in authenticity
you never met a young man with
principles man no in the game
when i learned when i meet in l.a you'd
be disappointed yeah
but uh you know good communication
authenticity
honesty all these things are important
absolutely for doing business for
relationships for everything absolutely
absolutely it's just a matter of
exercising your truth being who you are
and you know just getting what god got
for you for sure
all right 100. thank you so much
you know trying to give them reasons
every season you know why and the
reasons why
you know and i'm only 25. you know what
i'm saying i'm i'm trying to get
more reasons under my belt you know
you get them
for sure appreciate you man all right
thank you
you